if you're looking for something to hang
over your sofa I think this will catch
your eye this is something I checked out
at Christie's a couple of days ago this
is pablo picasso's 'women of algiers
version oh and it could set the record
for the most expensive piece of artwork
ever sold at auction Christie's
estimates this could go for some where
around 140 million dollars and just to
put that into some perspective for you
that's roughly with the movie furious 7
pulled in during its opening weekend and
what the New Orleans pelicans are
reportedly prepared to pay Anthony Davis
for a five-year contract if sculpture is
more your speed Christie's is also
oxygen off this giacometti this is
called pointing man and it's one of six
the Swiss sculptor made it's about five
feet eight inches tall so pretty much
life size and it could set the record
for the most expensive sculpture ever
sold at auction the price point on
pointing man is pretty similar to the
Picasso 130 million dollars now if
you're in this for bragging rights this
is who you'd be up against this is
Elaine win billionaire Elaine win she
currently has the record for having
spent the most on a piece of art at
auction back in 2013 the queen of Las
Vegas spent a hundred and forty-two
point four million dollars on this
triptych that Francis Bacon painted
Oh